what's happening there reject nation
thanks so much for clicking on this
video while disney plus day is going on
we're probably just waking up
but this video is being uploaded at this
hour so we had some spider-man stuff
come out this week there's always
spider-man stuff coming out but we
didn't cover any cosmic wonder what is
wrong with us what is wrong with you i'm
sorry i just i needed a break
they're just breaking never take a break
from cosmic wonder
it's the only thing we cover and it's
the only thing we'll ever cover so he
has today how toby and andrew will show
up in the spider-man no way home trailer
2. spoiler dies is what i'm putting in
the title i mean in his title it's
i'm going to say it right now click off
three two one at may dies you probably
heard that by now
[Music]
what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
pretty cool spider-man no way home news
won't be the judge of that holland
himself news coming from some insiders
and a plot leak that might tell us
exactly how sony and marvel studios plan
to tease toby mcguire and andrew
garfield spider-man in that first
official not teaser but official trailer
that we've all been waiting for so let's
start off by talking about how toby and
andrew if they are indeed in the movie
which most of us believe they are
especially after you know some of the
leaks that we've gotten in the past
couple of days how they'll be teased in
the official spider-man no way home full
trailer we're gonna talk about this and
talk about a possible major death in
spider-man knowing home that tom holland
has hinted at in a recent interview but
we'll start with this leaked description
of what to possibly expect from the
official trailer if this is indeed true
you know what i was thinking the other
day it would be so cool if we only see
like just a shadow of their suits
because now that the leaks are out
everyone's already heard about these
leaks people are going to be going out
there to just have that be confirmed for
them in
motion picture form you know what i mean
it's already out there the marketing for
toby and andrew has already been done
now pretty much been confirmed it's real
you don't need to show them at all i
don't think you could show them how yeah
i think the league took care of it and i
would now be very thrilled if they left
them out of the official trailer
entirely fikey god is weighing i think
so man they'd be
fine end of video we see willem dafoe's
goblin explaining to peter that if
strange sends them back to their worlds
they would die and he has to help them
we only see his face and he's wearing a
purple scarf we see some of the bridge
scene and peter parker saving some
people from the bridge and here's where
it gets intense it says that the trailer
ends with somebody saying that peter
will need help cut to a black screen and
then it shows two shadows walking
shadows we only see the shadows on the
ground and then a shot of peter with a
confused look the music that plays is a
mix of toby and andrew's soundtracks and
oh my gosh if this is true
this actually happens this alone is
enough to completely shatter the
internet and make everybody crap their
pants i think that's perfect i think
it's absolutely perfect to do it that
way i just said it a couple of minutes
ago yeah are the predictor of all things
marvel where there's much people who are
putting out fake leaks in the hopes that
the trailers will come out reflect the
way i want them to come out i don't
think it's necessary now no it just
doesn't seem necessary that seems
absolutely perfect him having the
confused look the shadows of them
and then the music being enough of an
indicator it's like if you were doing a
star wars trailer and then you saw a
shadow and then darth vader's theme
started playing you'd be like this darth
vader's gonna be you know it's the same
thing they should just like really
overlap their their music in just the
most distorted annoying ways like just
like play them both at the same time
yeah so it just sounds ugly and terrible
so like shrill to the ears like what is
that sound what awful confirmation of
the thing i've been waiting for all year
why total film and an interview they did
with tom holland in which he said some
pretty exciting and very interesting
things about the film while sitting down
with total film tom holland revealed
that spider-man know a home is going to
be a big surprise for fans but not in a
way that you may think he actually said
that the film is not going to be fun
it's going to be dark and it's going to
be sad this is what he had to say in the
interview what people will be really
surprised about is that it's not fun
this film it's dark and it's sad and
it's going to be really affecting you're
going to see characters that you love go
through things that you would never wish
for them to go through and i was just
really excited to kind of lean into that
side of peter parker now right away this
makes me think deaths not gonna lie i
think it's a terrible way to promote
your film guys you're gonna be miserable
watching this
get ready
to cry and to feel anguished
i can't believe you said that
you could do it like i think end game
and infinity war both have a lot of
darkness a lot of seriousness and a lot
of things that you don't want to
experience yourself but there's also a
lot of fun to be had i would be so
bummed if i watched this and i was like
that wasn't fun at all
watching all those characters returned
and then toby and andrew were just
gloopy and dark ever once fun
your friendly dour neighborhoods yeah
they're like let's borrow from the
amazing spider-man tone that's the one
golly my point being is i think there's
going to be a lot of fun to be i think
it's fun
yeah all right but i also like the
indication that it takes itself more
serious than the other two i like that
deaths are coming in this film now while
he's saying this he kind of made us
believe that maybe some other characters
are going through a lot of stuff but at
the very end he said he leaned into that
side of peter parker so it's probably
peter spider-man going through these
things that tom holland just mentioned
and not another character although i'm
sure some characters like mj and ned
will also be going through some stuff
obviously but the first thing i think of
is a death and there have been rumors
that aunt may could die and i've never
really liked this idea i don't like this
idea at all but tom holland is now
saying that the film's not fun it's dark
and it's sad and it's going to be really
affecting and you would never wish for
these characters to go through this aunt
may dying kind of fits that description
another theory on what this could be mj
or next
week that said perhaps at the end of the
movie and i should say spoilers if this
does end up being true it's just
strictly a rumor for now but there's one
supposed plot leak that says at the end
of the movie zendaya doesn't remember
peter parker at all and that would be
pretty sad too however i would say it
would open the door for gwen stacy to
come in for those of you who would like
to see that happen but it would still be
pretty tragic and it's also possible
that perhaps happy could die maybe ned
could die based off of what tom holland
strange to die
is going to die in this film and to top
this off daniel rpk did say something
similar to this on twitter about
spiderman no way home in a tweet he said
spiderman no way home will do to
holland's peter what i always wanted
make him suffer i don't hate holland's
peter or anything but that's the whole
point of the character he has to suffer
and lose everyone he loves this deeply
implies that somebody is going to die
and if i had to guess i'm definitely
going to say that it's probably aunt may
mj happy or ned there was a rumor that
perhaps toby maguire spider-man might
die but i just i hate that more than
anything bring back toby bring back
andrew let everybody freak out and then
give them a happy ending send them back
to their universes in peace or then
right when they show through the portal
gunshot
what is that new york cops got it guys
theory is the menace
or just you know whatever portal they
come through closes when they're halfway
through it
you know it's like a cronenberg movie or
something would be great that's the
thing is he used to have true personal
life consequences the weight of loss tom
holland will be returning for future
spider-man films and a lot of people
want him to finally come out on his own
not relying on anybody and if you take
away some of these characters from out
of his life he'll definitely have to do
that as sad as it sounds i think before
making himself reliant you got to make
him rely on everybody for three movies
in a row exhaust all horrors
here we go he's running out of people to
rely on
spider-man no one else to rely
spider-man no more mentors
it'll be good he'll be all alone
desolate he'll have no one to come fight
he'll become bruce wayne
i'm so excited for this man it's gonna
be great it's going to be a great time
yeah but not fun it's going to be
depressing and happy is going to get
decapitated like the opening scene what
a slow dower film that was it's like
watching the road or something jeez
michael hanukkah's spider-man no way
home what do you think about tom
holland's comments and how do you want
toby and drew drew to appear leave your
thoughts down below subscribe to cosmic
wonder it's a great friend of mine
i like him
hey
let's see what we covered for disney
plus day